I'd like to welcome everybody to our
discussion this morning we're gonna
start out with a discussion of
leadership with the two of my close
friends and master leaders and teachers
of leaders let me introduce them briefly
and then we'll start talking we'll spend
about twenty or twenty-five minutes
talking about leadership and so let me
start out with mr. Utley mr. Jeremy
Utley
so Jeremy has an interesting background
even as a young man he was in leadership
positions including he actually ran a
chick-fil-a early on in his life which I
think he laughs but that's good
experience they actually have a bunch of
people in their production goals as well
that sort of stuff then he was a
management consultant at a major
consulting firm I think will keep their
name out of this for this purposes and
but I think most critically for this
Jeremy along with Perry Cleveland we'll
get to in a second have been leaving the
efforts at the d.school which you've
learned about before and in particular
some of the stuff I'm interested in is
they lead large groups and try to teach
them how to become leaders when it comes
to innovation and you'll hear more about
that and so that's Jeremy I could go on
but I don't want to take too much time
and then our buddy
Perry Clavin who we've been working with
for years especially these guys work
together a lot on leadership issues and
Perry in addition to having taught
various kinds of creativity classes at
Stanford for over 15 years
Perry has been involved in various
companies he was the founding CEO of a
company called Atlas which designed and
then helped spread the first modern
snowshoe then he was a senior executive
at Patagonia and most recently who was
CEO of a messenger bag company called
Timbuktu so they're both guys who I
would describe as are in between two
parts of leadership one teaching it to
studying it and then also practicing it
so I think that's enough of an
introduction why don't we do a little
preparation for this maybe we should
start out and talk about teaching
leadership since you guys are really
into teaching leadership lately and a
lot of folks who are watching and
listening to this will be interest in
this why don't you kind of give these
your perspective on teaching leadership
sure great
thanks for having as well yeah we're
glad to be here always a delight so much
of what we want to talk about today
comes from some of our experience
specifically teaching folks leadership
in a class called D leadership which
which is a class at the design school
that's designed to actually send
graduate students into organizations to
lead design teams and so a lot of our
recent observations have come from
watching folks in various cultural
contexts with various industry and
functional challenges try to advance
ambiguous problem solving and creative
problem solving inside of organizations
so much what we're going to talk about
today comes from that experience right
and the first thing that we wanted to
show is a few cultural attributes that
we believe are critical to fostering a
new way of working and so these are as a
leader you've got to be focused on
culture first and developing the kind of
environment where people can thrive and
do the kind of work that you want them
to do and so we wanted to acknowledge
right away from the outset that
depending on the culture geographically
or organizationally you'll have to adapt
your style in order to be effective
we've had experience in Latin America in
South America and Asia in Africa and all
of the things we talked about have to be
amplified or diminished and tweaked to
achieve the leaders desired ends so we
want to acknowledge right from the
outset that you've got to be willing to
adapt and flex your style a little bit
can you give us a quick example of when
you had to adjust your style and
response to the culture I feel like
you're like yours you're setting me up
here so we had an experience actually
together working in the Asian context
one thing that we identified quickly a
lot of the work that we do requires full
participation and contribution from
everybody in the room and in some
cultures like like the culture that we
were working in we noticed that there is
there are hierarchy issues and there's
specifically folks feel a sense of
deference to Authority that when there's
a person with a higher rank or where
there's someone's boss in the room
people shutdown and we acknowledge that
early on as a real challenge to the work
we wanted to do because we wanted every
single person in this session to work
and contribute their best ideas and so
we see leadership as a design challenge
actually and so after the first day the
three of us got together and said okay
what are we gonna do to to affect
people's behavior system we actually can
achieve the outcomes we want to achieve
and we learned that f as we reflected on
these particular cultural challenges we
learned that people needed to feel
confident that they had time to to
articulate a statement that they
actually believed in and our leader our
style in this workshop was just throw
people in and then say what do you think
what do you think what do you think what
do you think
and we realized in the Asian culture
that put people on the spot and nobody
likes being on the spot in front of
their boss and so we get the second day
as we said are we need to change and
rather than asking people what do you
think and you have to respond
immediately in front of the camera we
said okay take two minutes everybody
write down a couple of things you think
and so we honored the fact that people
needed to feel a little bit more
equipped and prepared to answer a
question and then what we did to make
sure that everybody had a voice and felt
included we actually went around and
rather than asking people at random we
said now we're all going to share the
thing that we wrote down and so we had
every single person in the room share
and what that did over time is it it
gave the impression that everybody's
ideas are valid that no idea was
necessarily bad and that no one needed
to be afraid of what someone else were
in thought but it's subtle tweak to how
we were managed I said that I don't know
we were going in there that's an
interesting example the other part about
that is we had a member of our of our
team who was from Japan and a lot Yusuke
and Yusuke said the goal was to make it
so that it was embarrassing not to
participate rather than tumor dissipate
and I thought that was that was pretty
cool
changing a default yeah yeah okay did it
changing the social pressure that's
great so well so tell us more about how
you teach leadership I really I was a
little a side trip but an interesting
one so the want to talk for a moment
about the d.school and the differences
between design and design thinking so at
the d.school
we we teach a process called design
thinking
and that's the tenant of really how we
were gonna give this the leadership
class what what techniques and processes
were using and training the leaders on
and I think the key thing to think about
is the difference you're welcome to look
at the design school d.school website at
Stanford and read more about design
thinking but the difference is it's
subtle but the in design it's very much
usually individual effort and the
outputs are more about the particular
product and making something and getting
it done Design Thinking is more about a
collaborative effort a consistent and
repeatable process around innovation and
that's really where we get into is we
get into putting our students into into
circumstances where they need to affect
change and actually do drive innovation
in the organization with that want to
talk about the class itself we've got a
this this image you're saying is is how
we actually use our process on ourselves
so Bob will recognize these types of
posted those schedules and this type of
thing believe it or not this is the way
we start and we work for quite a bit and
even tell the moments before the class
is you're used to Bob we're changing
things on the fly but the key thing if
you can see the colors they're the the
class itself
there's an interesting construct we we
take some of the best students that have
been trained in this process called
design thinking when they've gone
through another class and been
recommended by other professors at the
d.school we interview them and recruit
them into leadership and they work in
duo's for the for the term and they head
off into companies so we've lined up I
think 12 companies or so this past year
so 24 students head off in pairs into
these companies each company having a
particular challenge they're facing so
one of them have note this last year was
Victoria Secret that wanted to change
their in-store experience so two
students went into Victoria's Secret
which is a massive undergarments company
that's global and they would try to
drive the innovation efforts around a
certain challenge that I think it was
around in-store merchandising abroad as
a fairer call so it was a really
challenging effort to get in there and
actually effect some change in the
company Saudi leaders head off and you
can see the column of red
head off for part of the week there in
the company's part of that week with
with us training and if you see the
column to the extreme right
there's also feedback loops so we have
the company giving direct feedback and
we deal with that to actually teach the
content in class so the thing that we've
learned in teaching this class that's a
big shift for students graduate students
at Stanford's are highly proficient they
are meticulous perfectionist and so
they're always thinking about how to
value the project and the big shift in
the leadership that we what you don't
see that's the closest thing that we get
to a syllabus that's that that picture
right there
it's funny when students ask for the
syllabus we send them a photo of a
whiteboard with a bunch post-its on it
say this is subject to change in fact we
know it will change but the thing that
we see over time is that students really
have to shift gears from thinking that
they are responsible for the project to
seeing that their team is responsible
for the project and it's a fundamental
shift and actually at the end with that
I think the crop missed the the last
presentation the partners themselves
have to make so rather than the students
who are leading Victoria Secret making
the presentation Victoria's Secret team
has to make the presentation so this
grade is a function of how they the team
performs so this is one thing I really
like about this approach to leadership
which is one that's actually been
written a lot about other places but the
way you guys are defining leadership is
it's not exactly what I do it's the
impact I have on others yeah that's
right and so I think that's really an
important point for anybody who's
thinking about what leadership is like
because you're not having a success or
an impact unless other people's behavior
are changing right and and so in the
classroom one of my favorite part is the
the students are fairly horrified to
discover that their grade isn't based on
what they do it's it's based on what the
people they are mentoring or leading do
which requires a shift right it requires
you to actually say rather than the
output of the project being my product
my product is the the capabilities and
the behaviors of the people who are on
the team and shifting their focus from
the end result to the team
but-but-but-but one of the reasons I
think that it's it's so interesting for
anybody who's interested in becoming a
leader is it's a change in focus on
others
from oneself and certainly have to focus
on yourself to manage yourself so you
can influence them and they don't think
you're crazy and all that kind of stuff
but but the whole thing is is is it
depends on the impact on others and no
matter how fantastic your essentially
your performance looks in the mirror it
doesn't really matter
right it's what they do right and we
judge a leaders quality and mettle by
how well they create other leaders and
so in this class of particular our goal
is for leaders to create leaders inside
of organizations and then the one thing
your job if you think about what are you
doing what are you making whereas if
you're responsible for the project
itself you're thinking about the product
or service whatever you're delivering
but if as the leader what you're what
you're doing and what your product is
besides the people is your creat your
cultivating conditions for the team to
succeed and so your job as the leaders
actually to design the conditions for
your team to thrive and to be acutely
aware of what is that one of the
expectations what's the tone what's the
culture that allows my that is enabling
my team to perform and to do the job
that they need to be doing and so you're
thinking about the people and then the
environment that you create around them
to enable them to succeed and that the
graph we draw constantly for the
students is a graph that essentially
says that your your participation in the
project itself by the end as
demonstrated by the final presentation
in this class being given by the company
not by the students are actually not
allowed to say anything there's a lot to
watch their their team actually present
the project is your your role in the
project decreases and you should see the
team's engagement increase so you should
be creating another leader in fact or
other leaders within that group and
giving up those process pieces Design
Thinking whatever the process is we've
we've actually put into the company and
we want to talk about that there should
be less and less of an active role so
this is a great example I mean one thing
I love about this classes it isn't just
this play exercised like we usually do
it really is when you look at great
ideas and movements that have spread
throughout industry just over the
weekend I spent a lot of time exchanging
email with a guy named Joe McCann and
Joe
that an effort that actually helped save
a hundred thousand lives and now in US
hospitals I mean to get rid of these
preventable medical errors and he had a
10-person team so it's sort of just like
yours little 10-person team and so we
said very quickly learned our definition
of success was when we left and they
didn't need us anymore
we had succeeded that's exactly the same
model you use it and I just love that
sort of that sort of definition and it's
kind of a multiplication typing right
well a lot of students come into the
class thinking it's going to teach me
how to be a consultant because that's
that's kind of the framework as a former
consult right they think they think it's
gonna teach me how to be your consultant
one thing that we say is no no no this
it's a fundamentally different thing
because you win when they stop calling
you right right it's just it's a
different model for people to get in
their heads because they as a high
performer you like to be needed right
right right but as a leader that your
your end goal is my team doesn't need me
that that's that's when you know you've
done a great job when they stopped
calling that's fabulous yeah so we can
get this we've covered this that your
goals work yourself out of a job the one
thing that we should talk about here is
what do you do in the interim right if
the end goal is get your team to stop
going if your end goal is to have your
team fully functioning and operating
with the capabilities and behaviors that
you want them to how do you get them
there and that when we talked about
leadership in that in the interim it's
really about striking the balance
between creating conditions and being a
facilitator of process and helping the
team see the right milestones and and
deliverables they need in the in the
midterm the other thing is actually
being an active contributor and being
almost the way we call it as the most
enthusiastic contributor and actually
striking that balance between getting
other people excited about the work but
then modeling the behavior by doing it
really well yourself and a lot of
students really it's it requires very
unique and complementary skill sets to
be able to both do the work that you're
asking people to do and then also give
them the space to do it themselves and
that's really it's kind of a tightrope
walk and that's what we do with a lot of
the classes help students know what
to read the how to read your team and
know what modality is required of you as
a leader is it better to worry about the
focus on the environment or is it better
to focus on how can I be modeling the
right behavior and learning when to do
what
so then the one slide that just has
these these acronyms DT and CT so design
thinking and critical thinking this is
something you've actually taught us to
be very aware above is in the
organization's critical thinking and
problem-solving is is what these
organizations are doing all the time so
we've talked about the tork Victoria's
Secret they are excellent at making
clothes delivering clothes getting them
on the Shelf having a shelf look
beautiful so all of a sudden this team
comes in and says well we want to figure
out how to communicate better with our
customers we want to change that store
experience we want to be more relevant
to a new consumer that's a completely
different way of working the innovation
the Design Thinking piece and the
critical thinking piece and there's a
plus sign in the middle and you know
that's the goal it looks like a simple
math equation but it's actually an
explosion when you put the two together
most of the time and that's the
challenge we put the bleedy leaders
right in the middle of is that company
desperately wants this innovation and
they love some of the questions that
it's that have been you know given to us
in the past but the idea is that's that
piece of it I think the amazing piece
right is putting those two together and
Charles O'Reilly one of your associates
talks a lot about this is it's a
constant state of conflict between those
two things is the thing we've kind of
come to realize it's not a ever a steady
state never magically fits together
there's no perfect culture that actually
these things fit together and it's
really how you manage as a leader to be
in the middle of that and deal with a
constant sort of conflict and they're
there there are trade-offs all the time
and one thing one thing that Charles
O'Reilly research has shown which is
fascinating for organizations who are
really trying to do disruptive work to
think about is that the capabilities
that are required to discover new
opportunities are actually in some ways
not just different from but actually
opposed to the capabilities that are
required to profit from those
opportunities and so as a leader how do
you cultivate the capabilities of
discovery while not shutting down the
capability of exploit oh this is sort of
interesting because this is
this balancing act that that what
Charles was talking about is essentially
if you want to have a repeatable process
goes over and over again you don't want
to have a lot of conflict maybe a little
bit of argument about how to make the
process a little bit better sometimes
you go back to doing it perfectly versus
waiting in the mess where you don't know
what the hell's going on at all and your
job is to sort of clean it up and it is
interesting just from watching you guys
deal with creative organizations trying
to get their mind around this and it's
it really is a different way of thinking
because they have to accept that it's
messy it's uncertain and they're not
going to be right and in fact I mean one
thing we've talked about this before
with Pixar I love the Pixar motto
Perry and I were just talking about this
that their perspective is that if you're
doing something that's ok then you're
screwing up because if you're gonna do
something do it has to really really
suck mmm because that's a sign you're
doing something something right so they
go from suck to non sadi
but biak ready to them is the enemy and
if you were teaching people to do a
routine task if they're doing a pretty
good but not a great job you'd be pretty
happy because you could say oh wait they
could learn how to fly the airplane or
do the routine surgical procedure but
you guys are teaching something much
more out there hmm so it's a different
sort of thing different kind of
leadership though the thing that makes
me think of is that back to this issue
of ambidexterity O'Reilly puts it that a
leader doesn't exist in a vacuum
you are not an individual autonomous
agent you actually it these kinds of
messy topics as you said they force
alignment issues among leadership teams
and how many people are responsible for
meeting in organizations and the
question becomes is there a place to
fight I think you talk about having a
safe place to fight and argue right is
there I know in Charles's paper he
mentions having a room that soundproof
yeah so that so that senior leadership
teams can do get out right now that's
what it requires it's not clean if
you're looking for clean and
operationalizing inefficiency that's as
you know variants reducing process if
you're looking for new and disruptive
it's inherently messy it inherently
requires trade-offs and you have to have
a team that's aligned that that's worth
it and then
willing to endure the fight to get to
the right yes I like where we're going
because let's think about five minutes
more and think especially for B for a
leader who is in charge of creative work
what's I don't take charts when the
create conditions where creative work
happens what are some of the other bits
of advice yeah you've got the authority
is they kind of we kind of breezed over
which is something attending our advice
I think one of the things that you've
cubed into with this class is we've the
structure of sending students into an
organization okay is interesting we send
students oftentimes in an organization
that they have no interest or very
little interest in working in so think
about that as a construct is where is
you Diego one of our associates Diego
Rodriguez talks a lot of a larger place
to fail right so we we set up this
construct were this is a federal company
they really want results higher better
than room service say student I forget
her team Kelly and and who were in David
we're in this company Victoria's Secret
neither one of them won a job in women's
apparel it's not an interest but they
this company very much wanted a certain
project done they engage they did it but
because they were in a new place a place
with sort of the risk and the load of
their career having to move up and all
this stuff have to happen there's in the
class I believe they took a lot more
personal risk and they tried on new
styles they wouldn't have tried before
and they tried new techniques and
success and failure they had their ups
and downs
they had points when Victoria Secret
called us up and said I'm not sure we
want to continue they had points for
Victoria said this is the this is the
best thing ever happened you know so but
that's part of the magic I think is if
you're a leader
one of things we see is very often they
you you sort of take the most important
project to work the the best team at
work and you say ok I'm gonna try this
new effort I'm gonna try on this new
style or I want to push to to do this I
my advice is find something maybe that's
not the fully-loaded
high-risk thing to do well what that
reminds me of in the the subtlety there
that's embedded in what you're saying
periods that we believe leadership is a
craft right and it's something that can
actually be honed over time through
experimentation and so rather than
thinking about your style is this fixed
thing think about your projects and your
teams as vehicles for your own
experiments
and actually learn to modulate your
style so and learn what works in what
situation so I like that because I think
that brings together and we've worked
together a fair amount I think the I
actually have interesting email from
professors having trouble teaching one
of my books too obnoxious MBAs in Hong
Kong
she's joy just over the weekend he said
you said leadership as a craft and you
can't do it unless you practice it a lot
what is it hefty with evidence-based
management and my reaction was well you
want a surgeon who knows all the latest
is read about and study all the latest
surgical techniques where do you want a
surgeon who's done a lot of operations
which ones you want well the answer is
both yeah
and so sighs you have it being an
evidence-based craft where people can
actually learn I think is is kind of the
Nirvana but but I mean III don't want a
surgeon who's trying who's read about it
really really a lot of times and I read
all the studies and has never done the
operation but I don't want the one who's
done a lot of operations maybe wrong his
entire or her entire life the one thing
that it's no those if you treat every
team and every project is if its life
and death and a surgical operation I
think it's your attitude is it's too
precious
yeah so that's the thing that's what's
wrong with ton of routine work and
high-risk work so I think that goes back
for a creative work you want to create a
situation where it's okay to fail and
one thing I would say that happens with
a lot of companies even though they
don't even talk this way is they've got
these big R&D budgets and they can spend
really a lot of money failing and it's a
good idea to spend a lot of money
failing you look at pharmaceutical
companies most of what they do fails and
they know it and it and that's just part
of the process of developing new
compounds so and you can do things like
testing wind tunnels and there's other
places you can test that failure is okay
it isn't just a matter it doesn't have
to be cheap sometimes most of the
venture capital firms in the Silicon
Valley most of the deals that they
invest in fail they know it but to get
those crumbs that are Union it's so the
question is what's yeah what's the
upsides part of it too there's also
pieces I think this whole thing of
critical thinking and design process and
I think the innovation process is messy
and you know our team leaders get into
these kind of you know the honeymoon
right they go in and it's fun to
brainstorm and it's fun these prototypes
but it's me surprise them I don't know a
couple weeks in and ask their their
their sponsors you know how much does
the senior management know about what's
going on the project
you know usually the ones having the
most fun the senior management knows
nothing and they're destined differently
whether you don't bring it back or or
they've engaged them too much you know
and they're having a lot of trouble
getting started we can't seem to get a
good meeting under about we can't seem
to get moving everybody wants to know
the details before we start everybody
wants to know when we're gonna deliver
we had this one company a New Zealand
company convey it I wanted to when can
we have the finished store design right
you know like week one you're never
gonna do a new store as I said the US
and they wanted the design you know they
they couldn't relax without you know a
senior manager is like I need that I
need something so I can relax then you
guys can have fun right they want to do
it backwards from the innovation that's
the challenge but that's a pretty good
leadership lesson I would say even for
more routine work which is that you
won't have enough support and cover for
the top but you don't let them in your
face constantly so a lot of what a
leaders job is is to figure out how to
create cover for his or her team and
legitimacy another way when they get out
of the way and but not having senior
management overly interested in it and I
mean over the years just I even back in
the way old days and youlet packard I
remember one of my students studied
successful versus unsuccessful out
efforts at youlet Packard and the least
successful ones usually were the ones
that the senior executives were most
interested in because they were annoying
the the development too much so whether
Trickett youlet packard at one point was
well you show them the bright shiny
things that distract the senior
executives but you do the real work in
the back because they'll mess it up you
know and so sometimes that's part of it
so yeah III think that probably just
about time to wrap up any sort of
closing comments on leadership
any closing advice I think the one man
say is that we use the indie leadership
we use the alumni quite a bit so the
only thing we've learned is where's your
mentor and we do it we do it very
structured we bring them in and we
actually oftentimes have this this
current group of D leaders are prepared
for whatever they're prepared for next
with us with their partners right so
they're about ready to go in and lead a
brainstorm session or
lead some kind of creative session to do
something we'll call it sure etic they
actually with alumni will run through
the first five or ten minutes of their
meetings and a lot of times they get
from the alumni the ability to manage
expectations and get a sense of a little
bit more perspective as to what's gonna
happen I think that's one things you
said good leaders I think good leaders
is just a function of mileage I think
the more and I think that's one thing I
think with I know from my career in
business is you put so much weight into
what you're doing you work months and
month month on rather than trying to get
more cycles and more projects and more
opportunities to lead under your belt I
think that would be the strong advice
I'd give that we give in leader could be
leadership is a very tightly constructed
seven weeks you saw it would be an
amazing deep dive into this stuff that
hands very dirty and they come out of it
I think much much better and you see
they get a few other opportunities in
there to leave smaller projects but I
guess the closing piece of advice I
would have is that trying to change
culture is a fool's errand and the goal
isn't what we found the goal is not to
change the culture but to find the
elements of the culture that support the
kinds of things you want to do and to go
where there's momentum there so you've
seen the design process and we're all
familiar with empathizing and rapid
prototyping it doesn't mean you
shouldn't force-feed it kind of wah grah
style right that's not the way to do it
what you should say is does the
organization care about customers then
that's a great place to start and talk
about customer delight right is the
organization maybe we've seen other
organizations that aren't really
concerned with customers but they love
product and so we say starting to go
where the energy yeah absolutely and
then and then you can kind of use the
judo move right it's if you're if you're
starting with prototyping then you say
we need to test this for customers
really quickly into a product driven
company then that makes sense but if you
lead with we got to empathize they go
what are you talking about and so it's
not about changing or fighting the
culture so much as finding the elements
of the culture that are aligned already
and then leaning into those elements to
accomplish your objectives so so I just
want to make one more comment and then
and then I think you switch gears but
but it is sort of interesting when I
hear peri talk and I hear the
description and I think this is
important for all of us who are involved
in the unstable organizations and lives
that so many of us have I'm one of the
lessons that comes from what you've done
and I think
of my buddy Tom Byers in the in our
entrepreneurship program here at
Stanford too is that if there's a bunch
of people who you've got our mentors and
you've Munter you've measured a bunch of
people and you all are connected to one
another so this is part of the effect of
your D leadership model and you're all
connected to one another it actually
doesn't matter that much what happens
with the company or the job you're
working in right now when things shift
you always got a group of people who are
going to take care of you and you're
going to take care of them and you're
going to be okay no matter what the
economy looks like or no matter what the
politics are in your organization if
you're just staying within a large
organization so to me that's another
implication it's some of its power in
politics but some of it is also besides
the fact that that's what leadership is
it's part of building a network for you
and your friends so you all can take
care of each other and feel both fight
more financially secure and more
emotionally secure because when things
go wrong you need help there's people
there to help you and there's also the
mutual obligation you're obligated to
help them so that's what that's one of
the I think that's one of the things is
I this class does the leadership class
that seems to be over but it's not over
I keep noticing that the gathering him
back together even though doing over
four months and I and to me that's a
sign that it lives on as an entity okay
so thanks so much so that was wonderful
and so and we'll have more conversations
in the future
I want to take a moment to thank Bob
Perry and Jeremy for a very enlightening
discussion today my name is Carissa
little and I'm the director of programs
at the Stanford center for professional
development and we've been delivering
education to industry for over 45 years
so we have reasonable experience
creating education programs to address
the career-long learning needs for
professionals managers and executives in
industry as a part of the School of
Engineering here at Stanford University
the Center for professional development
has worked with faculty and departments
to deliver degree programs online as
well as develop graduate certificates
from most departments in the School of
Engineering we extend a range of fields
from Electrical Engineering and computer
science to management science and
engineering where the design leadership
research you heard about today comes
from for graduate education our Center
extends a non-degree option which gives
students the opportunity to take
individual Stanford courses for credit
with this option you can enroll and take
a Stanford graduate course and the
quarter it is offering the graduate
certificates allow you to explore our
new areas of interest and strengthen
your current knowledge we have over 23
graduate certificates and areas from
energy technologies to international
security and data mining these
certificates are comprised of three to
five graduate courses and are can be
completed entirely online in addition
our mission has really been to extend
cutting-edge faculty research and
content to industry and so over the
years we've developed a series of
non-credit intensive short courses that
range from an hour long to full
professional certificate programs that
require an application we hope you
enjoyed today's discussion with
Professor Bob Sutton Perry Clavin and
Jeremy Utley Bob's graduate course
management science and engineering
number 280 organizational behavior and
evidence-based approach is being offered
online this fall bob has designed and
teaches this course on our new blended
learning platform to allow for more
teamwork and improved collaboration
between remote student
bob is also the academic director of the
Stanford innovation and entrepreneurship
professional certificate he also teaches
a course as a part of that certificate
titled leading innovation and Perry and
Jeremy have co-taught empathize and
prototype which is also a part of this
professional certificate these courses
are now available to enroll online and
the graduate course management science
and engineering 280 will open on August
1st for enrollment to learn more about
the topics in today's webinar or to
enroll please visit SCPD Stanford edu or
either of the websites that you see
undergraduate course or professional
education course enrollment if you have
any questions or need assistance please
contact our customer service team at the
email and phone numbers that you see on
the screen we hope you enjoyed today's
webinar and thank you so much for
joining us
you